Hey everyone, Ryan here, and welcome back to our oral medicine series.
This video will be all about diabetes.
So we're going to start with diabetes mellitus.
And mellitus comes from the Latin, meaning sweetened with honey, which refers to the
presence of sugar in the urine.
Now glucose is the main sugar that we use for energy as humans.
And diabetes mellitus leads to an excess of glucose in the blood.
High blood glucose is called hyperglycemia.
Now insulin is a hormone naturally produced by beta cells of the pancreas.
And insulin's job is to capture glucose in the blood and transport it into cells where
it can be used for energy, which is a good thing.
But if insulin doesn't function properly, or it just isn't produced, then glucose is
stuck in the blood where it builds up and that can actually be a bad thing.
Now glucose is a high energy reactive molecule and it'll actually cause oxidative damage
to the endothelial cells that lie in the blood vessels.
And damage to arteries can lead to atherosclerosis, which can in turn lead to hypertension, heart
attacks, stroke, and peripheral vascular disease.
And damage to capillaries can cause neuropathy, aka diabetic nerve pain, retinopathy and nephropathy.
So some bad things about having high glucose around in the blood.
Now some of the most classic signs and symptoms of diabetes mellitus include polydipsia, polyphagia,
and polyurea.
So this means that you're very thirsty, you're very hungry, and you urinate excessively.
So the saying goes you eat a lot, drink a lot, and pee a lot.
Now as a side note, there are also other mechanisms of developing diabetes such as diabetes
insipidus, and insipidus, instead of mellitus this time, refers to the word insipid, which
in turn is with regards to the passing of a lot of bland, colorless urine, instead of
the sweet sugary urine and diabetes mellitus.
So it's a condition where the kidneys are unable to retain water and this actually has
nothing to do with insulin or blood glucose.
So you just produce large amounts of urine because of a pituitary gland deficiency or
an insensitivity to ADH.
Now ADH, also known as vasopressin, stands for anti-diuretic hormone, and a lack of anti-diuretic
hormone will lead to diuresis or peeing.
So you're constantly thirsty, even if you have something to drink because you're constantly
peeing it out.
Diabetes isn't really an element for diabetes insipidus, it's all about the liquids here.
So you typically would treat this with a synthetic ADH, a low salt diet, and/or IV fluids.
But for the rest of the video though, we're going to shift back our focus to the much
more common diabetes mellitus.
So for type 1 diabetes mellitus, 5 to 10% of your diabetes cases are going to be type 1.
It usually has a juvenile onset, which means it usually affects children.
It's insulin dependent, which means that this diabetes depends entirely on a lack of insulin
production.
So usually some autoimmune reaction kills those beta cells, which usually produce insulin.
So insulin's not being produced naturally by the body, and these patients have to take
insulin synthetically.
Of course there's an insulin deficiency, as explained above, the body does not make
enough insulin.
And without insulin, there's no sugar inside these cells that desperately need energy.
So in the absence of sugar, cells are burning lipids, which produces toxic ketone bodies.
This is called ketosis if it's more mild, or ketoacidosis if it's more severe.
And this can result in a fruity smelling ketone breath.
There's no way to prevent this, and by this I mean there's a strong genetic component
to type 1 diabetes.
You can't blame diet or exercise here.
In all cases, if they're going to be managed properly, require insulin injections.
Now let's compare this slide to the next one, Type 2 Diabetes.
This one accounts for 85 to 90% of all diabetes cases, and it's one of the most common chronic
diseases out there.
It usually has an adult onset, which means it usually is the result of obesity, poor
diet, lack of physical activity, things like that.
It's non-insulin dependent, in other words it's more complicated, so there may be a component
of less insulin production, but more importantly, even if insulin's floating around in the blood,
the target cells are no longer sensitive to insulin, so it can't do its job.
So this is called insulin resistance.
The body can't use insulin properly, it's resistant to insulin's effects.
Most cases can be prevented, again usually the cause of obesity, poor diet, lack of physical
activity, and late stage cases may require insulin injections.
So early on, insulin really does you no good, but later on the pancreatic islets get burnt
out trying to produce more insulin all the time, and then you actually might need to
have synthetic insulin injections to try to help you out.
A third type of diabetes mellitus is called gestational diabetes, which occurs in pregnant
women who otherwise don't have diabetes, and it's due to placental hormones, and it's basically
a combination of type 1 with insulin deficiency and type 2 with insulin resistance.
So this usually resolves though after the baby is delivered.
So there are two main ways to measure diabetes, and the first one is blood glucose measured
with a glucometer.
This is the relatively easy way, and how it works is you wash your hands, you prick your
finger, and you place a drop of blood into this test strip that's inserted in the glucometer.
And the device then reads out your blood sugar in milligrams per deciliter.
So while it's relatively easy to measure, it's not reliable because blood glucose goes
up and down throughout the day, depending on when you eat and last, what you eat, and
when you took the measurement.
So we'll go over what a good measurement looks like in the next slide on classifications.
Now the second test we have is the HBA1C test, and this is a much more valuable test, and
it's also asked more on the board exam.
So this one stands for hemoglobin A1C, which is a glycated or glycosylated form of hemoglobin.
It's basically hemoglobin, which is that protein in red blood cells that transports oxygen
that's coated with sugar.
And importantly, this modification is permanent for the entire lifespan of that red blood
cell, which is about 120 days.
So a sample of blood will be taken, usually from your arm, and this test will tell you
the percentage of hemoglobin proteins in your blood sample that are coated with sugar.
And this gives you your blood glucose level over the past three months, because again,
that's the average lifespan of a red blood cell.
And the higher your A1C percent level is, the worse your blood sugar control and the
higher your risk of diabetes complications.
All right, now on to the diabetes categories.
And this is straight from the American Diabetes Association.
So there are three rows.
We have normal or healthy, we have prediabetes, which is the equivalent of pre-hypertension
or elevated blood pressure, it's not quite a disease state, but it is higher than normal.
And then we have diabetes, which is the equivalent of hypertension, but for blood sugar.
So hypertension is for blood pressure, diabetes is for blood sugar.
And the two often go hand in hand, it's what we call co-morbidities.
They tend to happen together, but not always.
And there are also three columns, we have the HBA1C, the fasting plasma glucose test,
and the oral glucose tolerance test.
And remember, as dentists, we're not diagnosing people with diabetes, we're simply evaluating
their current health status, and then we either modify our dental treatment and/or refer them
to a physician for further evaluation, diagnosis, and treatment when necessary.
So the HBA1C test is what we just talked about, it's taking a sample of red blood cells and
measuring the percentage of hemoglobin that's coated with sugar.
And this gives you a reliable look at the blood glucose situation for the last two to
three months.
And this is used by doctors to diagnose someone with diabetes, but for someone already with
diabetes, we want them to be ideally under 7%.
We want them to be under 7% for a relatively well-controlled situation.
These numbers here, 6.5% or above, 5.7 to 6.4 and below 5.7, are more used for diagnosis.
Again, if someone already has diabetes, we're looking for under 7% for a well-controlled
situation.
So, as dentists, we can ask a patient what their last HBA1C reading was to get an idea,
are they well-controlled at less than 7% or are they poorly controlled, which would be
above 8%, and that might inform how we proceed with treatment.
And of course, we want that HBA1C measurement to have been taken within the last three months.
Then we have the fasting plasma glucose test.
And fasting is defined as not having anything to eat or drink except water for at least eight
hours before the test.
And finally, the oral glucose tolerance test is technically pretty complicated, but basically
it involves you fasting for eight hours, and then you drink this really sweet drink and
then check your blood glucose two hours after that to reveal how your body processes glucose.
Alternatively, it can just be taken approximately two hours post-prandial, which means after
having a meal.
So, for fasting, we want to be below 100.
We want to be 99 or below.
But not too low, as we'll see in a little bit, too low can actually be a bad thing.
And then for post-prandial, we want to be below 140 or 139 and below.
For the pre-diabetes rows, these orange values are given different names depending on what
test was used.
So if you score between 100 and 125 with the fasting glucose test, it's called impaired
fasting glucose.
IFG would be what you would call that.
If you score between 140 and 199 with the glucose tolerance test, it's called impaired
glucose tolerance, or IGT.
And then findings in the red row would point to a diagnosis of diabetes.
Okay, so we talked about measuring, we talked about categories, now how do we manage diabetes?
Well for Type 1, it's all about getting that insulin.
And so you're going to treat it with self-administered, subcutaneous insulin.
And these are all synthetic derivatives of that hormone.
For this graph, the y-axis is intensity of the effect of insulin.
The x-axis is duration in hours.
So we'll start with the human insulin as a baseline.
Human insulin has a strong and relatively rapid effect.
For the synthetic forms, lispro, aspart and gluysine are rapid-acting forms.
They're stronger and faster-acting than the human insulin, but their effect dies down
pretty quick.
NPH, or neutral prodomine h-dorn, is a weaker and longer-acting form.
And then Glargine and Detimer are even weaker and longer-acting than that.
So a common prescription would be to combine one rapid-acting form of insulin right before
eating meals with one long-acting form of insulin per day to have a basal effect on
keeping glucose levels low and controlled.
So how about for type 2 diabetes?
Well, there are a plethora of different medications out there.
So let's go over some names and their mechanisms of action.
So so final ureas, also called insulin secreti-gogs, are typically taken 30 minutes before meals.
And their mechanism of action is to enhance insulin secretion by beta cells.
So we're increasing insulin secretion pretty directly.
And some examples of that are Glipazide, Glybyride, and Glympyride.
The bighuonides are taken with meals and their mechanism of action is primarily to reduce
glucose production.
And this is done by decreasing gluconeogenesis, liver production of new glucose, decreasing
glucose uptake from the intestines, and decreasing glucagon production, which normally moves
glucose into the blood.
So by a couple of mechanisms, the bighuonides, which are mostly metformin, is decreasing
the amount of glucose, reducing glucose production.
Next we have the dipeptidase 4 inhibitors.
These are the gliptins, and the gliptins are taken once daily regardless of meals.
And they inhibit the breakdown of the natural secreti-gogs, GLP1 and GIP, which are natural
hormones that stimulate insulin secretion.
So by inhibiting those enzymes, they indirectly enhance insulin secretion.
So again, I'm going to say this one is increasing insulin by inhibiting the dipeptidase 4 enzyme.
Next we have the thiazolidin diodes.
And these are glitazones.
These are the glitazones.
These are taken with meals.
They improve insulin sensitivity, particularly for fat and muscle cells.
And especially they produce more glucose transporters, so insulin will have a more profound
effect and suck more glucose into those cells.
So for this one, we can say it decreases blood glucose by increasing glucose transporters.
So those are often called GLUTs, glucose transporters.
Alright then we have the alpha-glucosidase inhibitors.
These are administered just before meals, and they function to delay carbohydrate digestion
in the gut.
So basically they block the breakdown of polysaccharides into glucose by this alpha-glucosidase
enzyme in intestinal cells.
And if you inhibit this enzyme, you excrete glucose instead of absorbing it.
However, leaving more sugars in the intestines for bacteria to ferment can cause some problems.
They can cause abdominal pain, nausea and diarrhea, which are common side effects from a carbose
and migletol.
So we can say for this one, you're losing glucose because you're excreting it rather
than absorbing it in the gut.
And for our final row, we have the sodium glucose co-transporter to inhibitors.
And these are the glyph lozins, and they selectively inhibit this co-transporter, which is expressed
almost exclusively in the proximal convoluted tubule in the kidney.
So this will cause you to urinate glucose instead of reabsorbing it.
However, just like with the above row, leaving more sugars in the urine can feed bacteria
in the urethra in the bladder, causing urinary tract infections.
So similar to alpha-glucosidase inhibitors, this is going to decrease the amount of glucose
by increasing the amount that we're excreting this time in the urine.
Alright, so hopefully that's helpful to break down those rows and the different drugs that
can be used to treat diabetes.
I know these can appear on the board exams.
So there are two extremes of the blood sugar spectrum that we have to talk about.
And they're hypoglycemia, which is low blood sugar, and hyperglycemia, which is high blood
sugar.
And someone would have hypoglycemia if they're less than 70 mg per deciliter of blood glucose.
And actually this is what we're most concerned about for a diabetic and the dental chair,
because they are then at risk for insulin shock.
That's too much insulin, not enough sugar.
The lower the blood sugar, the higher the risk.
And this might seem totally counterintuitive, especially from the last slide that we talked
about all those medications.
Basically, everything we've talked about up to this point has been how do we reduce blood
sugar for diabetics.
But if it's reduced too much, then they can pass out via insulin shock.
And that's a medical emergency.
So there's a happy medium that we're shooting for.
Now if they're hypoglycemic and conscious, then we can give them orange juice or a glucose
tab some quick form of sugar to boost their levels and avoid insulin shock.
Then you can wait 15 minutes and then retest their sugar level.
If they're hypoglycemic and have already passed out, then it's a medical emergency we need
to call 911 and administer intravascular dextrose or intramuscular glucagon to help boost their
sugar levels.
Now either way here, we want to arrange for them to have an escort to drive them home.
So what are some signs and symptoms of hypoglycemia that we can look for?
Well I love this little memory tool.
Cold and clammy need some candy.
So you're feeling cold and sweaty, these are cardinal symptoms, and then getting some
sugary candy will help resolve them.
I also made up this pneumatic, tired, which stands for tachycardia, irritability, restlessness,
excessive hunger, and diaphoresis or sweating.
So a nice little card here to help you remember some of the key factors and things to remember
for hypoglycemia.
And then on the other hand, we have hyperglycemia.
So the specific numbers for hyperglycemia are at least 126 milligrams per deciliter
for fasting, at least 200 milligrams per deciliter for after a meal.
So the same as that red traffic light from the classification or category slide.
So how do you avoid or manage this?
Well you would promote exercise, eat less, and take insulin as directed.
It's not as immediately dangerous as hypoglycemia in the dental setting, but if it's chronically
high, it can lead to life-threatening complications like diabetic ketoacidosis that we were talking
about before, or hyperosmolar hyperglycemic state.
Now how about signs and symptoms of hyperglycemia?
Well I also love this memory tool, hot and dry, sugar high.
So you feel hot and thirsty thanks to having too much sugar.
And I also made up this pneumatic, sinful, which stands for sweet breath, that ketone
breath, increased thirst, nausea and vomiting, frequent urination, polyurea, and loss of
clear vision or blurry vision.
So cold and clammy needs some candy, hot and dry, sugar high, hopefully you can remember
those catchy little phrases and that can help you remember stuff on the board exam.
Alright so here we are with our flowchart on how to manage diabetic patients.
And you may notice this one looks pretty similar to the hypertension one where a well controlled
situation has some treatment modifications while a poorly controlled situation requires
some bigger decisions to make.
So if a diabetes is well controlled, the HBA1C and the glucose are in a safe range based
on what we just talked about, then all routine dental procedures can be performed with only
a few extra considerations.
The short morning appointments are usually best.
We want to avoid aspirin and other NSAIDs in patients taking sulfonal urea drugs because
they can worsen hypoglycemia.
One of the side effects of oral glucocorticosteroids like prednisone is that they can increase blood
glucose levels and increase insulin resistance, making diabetes and hyperglycemia worse.
So avoid them when possible.
Levofloxasin is a potent antibiotic that can be used to treat oral infections, but it can
also lower blood glucose levels and worsen hypoglycemia.
So again avoid that if possible.
We want to advise the patient to take their usual insulin dose and normal meals on the
day of their dental appointment and confirm this with them at the appointment.
We want to use an office glucometer prior to dental procedures to ensure good glucose
control, and we're specifically trying to avoid hypoglycemia more so than hyperglycemia.
We want to have a glucose source ready, orange juice, soda, cake icing, and give it to the
patient if those cold and clammy symptoms start to occur.
I'd probably also add to this to be slow to change the chair position because diabetic
neuropathy can affect the integrity of the vasculature, and these patients may be at
more risk of orthostatic hypotension.
Now if glycemic control is poor, or if signs and symptoms point to an undiagnosed problem,
then there are some additional precautions that we should take.
If it's an elective procedure like an ascetic restoration, I would defer treatment and make
sure they follow up with their physician to get things back under control.
If it's an urgent procedure however, extracting an infected tooth, then we have to consider
are they asymptomatic or symptomatic for life-threatening ketoacidosis, etc.
And if there are no symptoms, ideally we would call the physician before proceeding if possible,
and then you'd want to manage any infections pretty aggressively in these patients by incision,
drainage, extraction, pulpotomy, and antibiotics because they have a reduced ability to fight
infection, and then we would refer them to their doctor.
If they are symptomatic, then we are immediately referring to the emergency room, get them
to the hospital where they could administer intravascular antibiotics, manage their insulin
levels appropriately, things like that.
One other thing to consider, brittle diabetes, which is very uncontrolled diabetes, you have
a higher than 200 milligrams per deciliter of fasting glucose and/or an HBA1C that's
greater than 9%, you might want to consider antibiotic prophylaxis before proceeding
as we discussed in our antibiotic prophylaxis video.
And again, these guidelines are a bit of a grey area, some dentists may disagree on
some of the things I have here and when to defer treatment, when not to, but this is
what I use in practice and the numbers I discussed in this video, I'm confident they're what
you should know for the board exam.
Also since there's a big correlation between diabetes and hypertension, you would only
follow any of the hypertension guidelines from our last video, like epinephrine restrictions,
only if their blood pressure indicates to do so.
And then there are a few oral manifestations of diabetes to be aware of.
Dry mouth or zerostomy is a big one and it contributes to a lot of the other ones on
this list.
Burning mouth is one of those, a burning mouth sensation.
A delayed wound healing is due to peripheral vascular damage, increased incidence and severity
of infections, this goes hand in hand with the delayed wound healing, increased risk
of carry thanks to dry mouth and increased glucose in the saliva, oral candidiasis also
thanks to dry mouth, glucose and increased infection rate, prodigland enlargement due
to compensatory hyperactivity of the salivary glands, try to make up for that dry mouth,
and then gingivitis and periodontal disease.
Again, zerostomyia, sugar, changes in the oral microbiome, all to blame.
So to finish up, I once again came up with just two scenarios here covering some frequently
asked questions that I get.
So a lot of people ask me, you know, what would you recommend for a diabetic patient who
is undergoing a procedure with general anesthesia?
Now, usually severe diabetics should not go under general anesthesia if at all possible.
Well-controlled diabetics can, but the typical recommendation for both IV sedation and general
anesthesia is fasting from midnight the night before the procedure and using only half the
usual insulin dose, and then supplementing with intravenous glucose during the procedure
as needed.
For the second scenario, the patient has trouble remembering if they took their insulin today.
Now might sound silly, but there's actually a well-established link between memory loss
or amnesia and diabetes, and that's because uncontrolled diabetes increases the risk of
cognitive problems like amnesia when you have a higher-than-normal blood glucose level
that can damage nerve cells and blood vessels and peripheral nerves of the body and the
brain.
Now, in terms of what you should do, it really depends on their most recent HBA1C and their
blood glucose level in the chair, and you can go back to our flow chart and decide how
to proceed based on your findings and your concerns.
That's it for this video guys, thank you so much for watching, please like this video
if you enjoyed it, and subscribe to this channel for more on dentistry.
If you'd like to support me, please check out my Patreon page.
Thank you to all of my Patrons here for their support.
You can unlock access to my video slides to take notes on and practice questions for the
board exams.
So go check that out, the link will be in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone, I'll see you in the next video.